while some construction companies are
claiming they aren't being paid for work
being done on the more than two billion
dollar concert venue MSG sphere so there
is a court hearing schedule for next
week on one of those lawsuits eight news
now reporter Joshua peguero digs into
the claims he joins us now live near Las
Vegas Boulevard to break it down for us
Joshua
hello Brian Denise with the band U2 as
its opening act the msg's fear is
expected to open in late September it's
being built as the largest sphere in the
world and it can house up to 20
000 seats yet two lawsuits filed in
Clark County Shed lights on issues
regarding its construction
one lawsuit filed by Construction
Company Ryder Levitt bucknall in 2021
claims it's owed 3.1 million dollars in
arguments before George Nancy Alf
lawyers for writers say quote this
project is the brainchild of Jim Dolan
James Dolan is the CEO of MSG which owns
the New York Knicks New York Rangers
along with Madison Square Garden Riders
lawyers told judge Alf they blame him
for not getting paid saying quote Mr
Dolan was critically involved in the
payment of everyone most importantly
Ryder Levitz my client and he absolutely
was involved in stopping the payments to
my client they argued before judge Alf
where the issue stems from quote there
was supposed to be the world's longest
bar in this project and they built it
and then he came through and deleted it
and wanted to take it out he increased
the project cost Mr Dolan's decision
against advice increase of project costs
and now he's blaming us for increasing
the project costs Dolan's attorney
responded saying there's no proof he had
knowledge quote none of these documents
lead to the conclusion that it is Mr
Dolan who has this unique personal
knowledge that can't be obtained through
other people lawyers for Rider and MSC
are scheduled to appear in court next
week on June 13th in its most recent
Financial earnings report MSG shows it
has paid 2 billion in construction costs
already and the project is expected to
cost him 2.3 billion dollars
now earlier this afternoon we received a
statement from sphere entertainment to
subsidiary of MSG and it reads quote
this story has no merit the filings
clearly show rlb the construction
company was fired for cause Denise
Joshua thanks for that and a footnote to
the story in another lawsuit submitted
back in December of 2020 another
construction company this one called
Harris Rebar claims it's owed 3.3
million dollars that suit is against the
former general contractor who's working
at the site but records show that Harris
Rebar filed a lien in February claiming
it sold nearly 2 million dollars after
the developer made some payments